england's return to international
football has been blighted by racism yet
again
raheem sterling and jude bellingham were
both subjected to what appeared to be
monkey chants
cups and other objects were also pelted
at sterling from the crowd
something manager gareth southgate calls
unacceptable
we weren't
totally
well we weren't conscious of it on the
side and i don't know whether the
players on the pitch were
we have to hope that we can continue to
eradicate racism from not only football
but from life in general
the fa2 released this statement
it is extremely disappointing to hear
reports of discriminatory action towards
some of our england players we will be
asking fifa to investigate the matter we
continue to support players and staff in
our collective determination to
highlight and tackle discrimination in
all its forms visibly disheartened by
events at the puskas stadium in budapest
hungary's head coach marco rossi issued
this apology i'm sorry that happened i'm
sorry but
what i can say
is that what we can control what i can
control
it was respectful for everybody players
and everybody
also not in the pitch
but despite the torrent of abuse england
returned to winning ways slotting four
past the hungarian national team in a
world cup qualifying match
the three lions will be hoping to go one
step further on their euro 2020 success
in qatar next year and maybe just maybe
bring football home
for now footballing buddies will need to
come up with a solution to the scourge
of racism in the beautiful game
shaman freeman powell sky news